[Applaudissements]
reste aussi dans les marseillais voilà
les marseillais sur w9 bien entendu ce
sont des marseillais qu'on amène à on
envoie un petit peu partout dans le
monde et notre héros s'appelle toujours
grecque alors la semaine dernière greg
avait le coeur qui balançaient entre
maeva et mélanie parce que la barre
brian et il se choppe il se pécho ça se
pécho sa soeurette et finalement
vendredi s'est arrêtée définitivement
sur mélanie en lui promettant enfin
d'être sérieux
regardez aux atouts et capituler
regardez où il en est aujourd'hui
regardés et un coeur et que je réfléchis
avec mon coeur tout simplement tourner
la page maintenant j'y aille de l'avant
je te préviens c'est au moins la dixième
fois qu'ils me le dis ils sont pécho ils
ont fait remaniée d'eau très court un
bravo donc sauf que samedi les
marseillais ont eu la bonne idée de
jouer à action vérité je vous le fais
tout ça je crois qu'on envoie quand on
se croyait ni moi aussi j'en ai fait il
ya deux semaines on vous dit c'est plus
quand on est jeune ça bah oui mais non
mais tous vous de le faire avec ma robe
pour fait des actions vérité avec votre
maman elle cherche le fait que ma robe
elle le sait la draf wells et l action
ces thèmes et où une boulette sur le
front alors il ya 220 ne pas louper si
vous allez voir ce qu grec a fait comme
action avec son ex maeva et vous allez
voir l'argument que greg va utiliser
auprès de sa chérie mélanie pour
justifier son geste
généralement quand on veut plus chaud de
meuf on organise toujours un action
vérité et la 'règle d'or' à ma tête à
moi l'a tous fait et après ça devient
que des actions au bout d'un moment les
vérités on s'en fout total gabon co des
hauts des bas salaires alors laisse que
tu sortirait avec thibault et donnant
alors vous allez sortir dehors nous
allons salon privé où vous allez vous
galant sa partie
comme lors de votre premier bisou en
attente les yeux de ma mère tu vas voir
attention à toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout
je vais chercher toutes les études de
médecine légale je promets
[Applaudissements]
abdou fall in love queen mais je
n'embrasse pour te prouver que j'en ai
rien à faire là bas j'ai dit regardez
moi je l'adoré taillables élèves alors
ont évidemment que m'a fermé la nuit à
votre ami elle va se bon et alors sauf
que greg et comprends absolument pas
pourquoi c'est vrai il n'a rien fait de
mal le pauvre homme bien mais ça ne
m'allait je comprends pas pourquoi pas
non heureusement moi je me dis c'est un
je suis d'accord moi je suis avec nous
ils obligés de faire ces actions que
ménage chez vous du tout la vérité quand
c'est une action mais ça ça reste un
gros naze quand même tu m'as vu en
devant la télévision mais oui il ya un
minimum la fille voilà intéressant vous
allez mettre la langue alors tu veux
dire
regardez regardez quand même la mauvaise
foi de greg pour moi c'est le number of
shadow embrasse pendant 10 secondes avec
la langue
mais l'adage accepte civile a dit oui
même pas 30 secondes en fait la range
dans un délire de gamineries est dans un
délire de cour de récréation
[Musique]
houston les erreurs moi le problème
c'est que quand j'ai embrassé maybach je
n'ai pas fait des caisses moi le
problème c'est que quand j'ai embrassé
maybach je n'ai pas fait dit il
[Applaudissements]
velador sa mauvaise foi c'est peut-être
pas vraiment ça
mais oui alors moi je me mets dans sa
peau non mais tu seras telle manière et
je me suis un peu d'accord avec lui mais
vous faire voler la menace pas moi je
vous le dis moi j'aurais pas qui fait ce
qu'elle a fait sa meuf madame et ses
nuits
[Rires]